[Música]
muy buenas noches américa latina'
bienvenidos a esta actualización de
noticias en france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález comenzamos en américa del sur
el presidente de perú pedro castillo
completó el gabinete de ministros con el
nombramiento de los encargados de la
cartera de economía y de justicia -pedro
frank y liderará el ministerio de
economía y finanzas es considerado de
una izquierda un poco más moderada y
tendrá el reto de impulsar la economía
peruana en la era post pandemia el
jurista aníbal torres encabeza el
ministerio de justicia ambos juraron en
su cargo un día después de ser
presentado el pleno del gabinete porque
aparentemente tenían discrepancias con
el presidente castillo quien ha sido
también criticado por tener un ejecutivo
compuesto por figuras muy polémicas y
por la baja participación de mujeres
[Aplausos]
en francia miles de personas volvieron a
tomarse a las calles de parís y de otras
ciudades de ese país europeo para
manifestarse contra la extensión del
pase sanitario para que sea utilizado
para poder ingresar a bares restaurantes
trenes hospitales entre otros a pesar de
que la mayoría de las marchas fueron
pacíficas hubo reportes de incidentes
menores y también enfrentamientos en
algunos puntos del país de otra parte
las autoridades de los territorios de
ultramar de la isla de martinica en el
caribe y de la isla de la reunión en el
índico impusieron nuevamente
confinamientos estrictos ante la baja
vacunación y el aumento de casos de kobe
hablamos ahora de méxico este país
última detalles para la consulta popular
promovida para avalar el juicio a los
expresidentes de ese país por delitos
cometidos durante sus respectivos
gobiernos para muchos sectores esta
consulta tiene como intención ser un
primer paso para conocer los hechos de
corrupción o delitos ocurridos en el
pasado que permitan hacer justicia a las
víctimas
el mecanismo completamente inédito en la
historia mexicana no está lejos de la
polémica por considerar que la justicia
no se consulta de manera electoral
durante la jornada hubo diferentes actos
para promover la participación de los
ciudadanos que a su vez se muestran con
opiniones muy divididas en cuanto a esta
consulta
yo creo que esto que estaba hacer es
meramente populista por parte del
presidente si él realmente quiere
aplicar la ley se aplica pues si está a
favor de la consulta porque no te exime
de la ley ser político vamos ahora hasta
turquía el presidente de ese país recep
tayeb erdogán declaró el estado de
desastre en las regiones del país que
son afectadas por los incendios
forestales que dejan hasta el momento 6
muertos y más de 400 heridos la zona más
crítica es la turística región costera
de antalya aunque hay otros 10 incendios
activos que también están afectando
otras regiones en donde bomberos y
vecinos de la zona intentan extinguir
las llamas que han devorado ya viviendas
y bosques nativos desde bruselas la
unión europea ofreció ayuda a ankara
para ayudar a sofocar las llamas que
podrían extenderse si se mantienen las
condiciones de viento clima seco y
cálido por el verano
y vamos ahora con las últimas noticias
que nos llegan de los juegos olímpicos
de tokio 2020 la jamaiquina elaine
thompson se consagró campeona en los 100
metros lisos femeninos y también alcanzó
su tercer oro olímpico república
dominicana logró la presea de plata en
los 4 por 400 metros mixtos de atletismo
francia por su parte se llevó la medalla
de oro en judo tras vencer a japón y en
tenis femenino la suiza belinda benchi
ganó oro en la final derrotando a la
checa marketa pondrá sopa
es todo por el momento sigan con france
24 muy buenas noches